here's what would happen if the largest  asteroid hit earth  let's start small the 20 meter long  chelyabinsk meteor actually hit earth in  2013 and caused the equivalent explosion  of 500 000 tons of tnt  oh okay thinking bigger now throwing it  back 65 million years the 10 kilometer  chicks a lube asteroid was so strong  it's probably what caused the dinosaurs  to go extinct if earth took a hit from  the largest body in the asteroid belt  ceres  there would be no more earth it's so big  it's technically a dwarf planet the  ceres would block out the sun and remove  10 kilometers of the earth's crust bennu  is the one you'd want to worry about  this 490 meter wide rock has a 1 in 1700  chance of colliding with earth in  september of the year 2182 so